King Charles and queen Camilla have
started their summer holidays this week
like much the rest of you apart from
they go to the traditional bowel marrow
of course I've been Scotland joining
them over the weekend for a summer in
the highlands in what many see is
something of an olive branch was
disgraced to a younger brother to the
king prince Andrew not being offered an
olive branch is Prince Harry who hasn't
received the invite to peace talks many
were expected to take place next month
so what does this all mean for the
Renegade Royals joining me to discuss
all of this joined by the author and
historian Tessa Dunlop the host of die
for daily podcast Kenzie Schofield and
commentator Hilary fordwick thank you
all three of you for joining us sir for
this discussion it feels like a test is
in the studio with me Tessa it feels
like a while since we have done royals
here on Piers Morgan said I've been the
chair for a couple of weeks now and
there was a period of course all through
the year where there were so many Royal
events and so much to talk about have
you found it a bit quieter a bit and
then um a certain individual didn't turn
not down under and there was a little
storm in a teacup and your Alter Ego
appears I noticed as disconsolate and he
actually tweeted you know he should be
on the plane mate or hrh or however he
referred to him and I thought peers have
you spent so long hammering away Harry
and Andrew that you've forgotten that no
one is a saint not even the king and the
next in line to the throne and yes it
was a chance for William to broaden his
base and I'm afraid he scored a bit of
an own goal but peers isn't here to
defend himself but he did certainly
tweak that you brought up Andrew there
now prince Andrew this is what we've
advised him to talk about he is this it
coming in for the cold what do you read
into it well and Kinsey will be hot off
the calls because she's uh Stateside
where they've just released
um this big tell-all or tell more
documentary on Andrew including
interviews with Emily matless who of
course delivered that was meant to be a
sort of courtroom style interview in
Buckingham Palace which Hook Line and
sink at Andrew but certainly there is
more coming out I think the wish was
from the prince that he could cool your
hand over was it about 12 million I
think there's some undisclosed including
some money apparently from the late
Queen and it would all go away no such
luck Andrew and you might be up in
Balmoral right now or heading up there
but that doesn't mean people aren't
talking about you let's come over to
Kenzie then you bought her up Kenzie
joins us thanks so much from Stateside
uh time to bring prince Andrew in what
do you read into it
I I think he's still a liability to the
royal family perhaps more so than Prince
Harry and Meghan Markle uh you know it
was the Queen's wish that they could
stop the bleeding when it came to this
story and look at us today we've got
hours and hours of additional interviews
and people dissecting the Jeffrey
Epstein Scandal I don't think I know
time heals all wounds but we need more
time when it comes to prince Andrew I
think that
um you know I just think that this was a
such a destructive uh destructive
incident and I do fear that it could be
his legacy destructive and
internationally renowned of course Let's
cross over to uh Hillary as well and
talk about the Prince Harry element in
this because uh Tessa began by saying
it's sort of almost like an own goal
being scored you know we've had Harry
heading over to Singapore he's playing
in a pilot match he got criticism for
that uh he's now I believe back in
Montecito but this idea that he was
going to print peace talks with King
Charles and that's now off the agenda do
you think we are going to see any sort
of reconciliation
well pleasure to be back with you again
and good afternoon Stateside as you
mentioned evening there but a few things
the biggest news actually with regard to
Harry is something that the mainstream
media and I don't know whether it's just
that it's not quite public yet the
biggest news is with regard to Edward
Long Edward long was referred to in
Prince Harry's um sort of damn all
autobiography throwing the royal family
under the proverbial bus he was referred
to as the bee he is one of the courtiers
he was very loyal for many years to the
queen our late beloved Queen now King
Charles has honored him he now will be
Lord young and he now will be taking on
Royal events for the king in his absence
so in abstentia he will be made in the
position of the king what does this mean
this literally is taking sides it's
saying who matters it's saying who has
been dedicated to duty and it is not at
all obviously what Prince Harry would
ever have wanted so I think now you can
see definitely where the lines are being
drawn now the king of course has a big
heart obviously most fathers would love
to reconcile with their son but I think
this is a huge move we're seeing with
regard to Lord Young
I I think you make an interesting point
Hillary but in perhaps some ways you put
20 together and you make five Harry is
not a working member of the royal family
the likelihood of him rubbing up against
um Lord long in the near future or the
distant future is pretty minimal and
actually what needs repaired within the
royal family are those personal
relations between William Charles and
Harry and I think we've spent too long
as a media and I include all of us
lobbing uh
criticism back at the sussexes ah Andrew
these guys really they're pretty
irrelevant when it comes to the state
institution that is the monarchy how do
we go forward and future proof that
monarchy that I think all of us here
believe in
um and make sure that things like mexit
as people uh refer to it or the prince
Andrew debacle that keeps on bleeding as
Kinsey put it don't happen again and
that I believe requires written Branch
reform that we could push for in the
press that we could properly get down
and dirty and look at what's working for
that state institution monarchy and what
isn't but instead we're going for this
soap opera side show oh look what
Charles has appointed he's appointed a
man that Harry won't like and it's
actually I don't think helpful for
anyone let's bring in Kenzie's Lord go
on go on Hillary I'll give you a chance
to respond go on yes Lord young not long
um I think it's very important to see
the continuity I think it's very
important to see what does matter I
think this is a great move in terms of
what does matter and of course Prince
Harry isn't working anymore as a senior
role due to his own decision yes uh
Kinsey want to bring you back in on this
and ask about the other gentleman
involved in probably a lot of these
proposed peace talks and decisions
Prince William the brother of Prince
Harry uh quote uh feels utterly betrayed
by what Harry wrote about him in his
book spare and said about him on Netflix
they were very close growing up it's
been very painful for him of course do
you think he is having an outsized role
in this uh proposed reconciliation
well that's certainly what The Daily
Beast is reporting The Daily Beast is
reporting that he is the one that
stepped in and said that absolutely not
they were not going to have peace talks
with Prince Harry that you know that
incident that happened right after
Prince Philip's funeral that private
moment where Prince William was begging
him to please listen to him and his
father ends up in you know the first
chapter of spare that's a complete
violation of their privacy and you know
that I do believe that Prince William
would likely
prefer to keep a distance from Prince
Harry at this point in time the Sussex
brand is toxic and I don't think he
trusts them
let's go on Tessa well I I hear that and
I totally understand between siblings it
can get really personal but what you
have with the institution of monarchy is
it's a state gas and through those fault
lines runs a family and sometimes
William has to be encouraged to sit back
to take a bigger View and think what
looks best for monarchy what's actually
going to work in terms of the monarchy
going forward his father is defender of
the faith he's meant to be a leading
Christian that's meant to be about
forgiveness about reconciliation and I
would like to see that from our monarchy
please Kenzie but do you not feel like
it makes the entire monarchy look weak
to take absolute kicks in the teeth
between Netflix between spare and then
say no come on back we'll take some more
you know not knowing confidently that
things that they say in their presence
might not end up spoken out loud to
Oprah Winfrey on live television or end
up in a podcast in the future I think
they're protecting their brand think
they're protecting their sanity and
their mental health because you know I I
can't imagine what it's like to say
things out loud and to have those
Secrets whispered on International
television or in a podcast or book or
Netflix series I think that they're
trying to protect their future by
distancing themselves are actually also
doing the right thing which is
dedication dedication to duty that's
what they're doing they're keeping calm
they're carrying on and they're doing
what the British public and members of
the Commonwealth and everyone actually
seems to admire decent people dislike
dishonesty and they respect and admire
Duty and you actually saw that also with
recent polls with regard to Prince
William of course in the U.S he was
ranked even higher than President Biden
and the king and that's mainly a lot due
to his dedication to duty and and
Hillary we hear a great deal from those
who really support the monarchy they
have a loud voice they have a live voice
and establishment media and rightly so
they're proud of that institution we
don't hear from the 25 of britons who
actively want want to see the end of
monarchy I don't think by the way
William helped his cause when he didn't
think oh I'm gonna sit on a plane for 22
hours it is a pain in the neck but I'm
going to do it because people like the
14 year old kid that's going to be
walking alongside my son's reign will
buy into that and see that I gave up
some of my holiday and did it and
actually what I think we need to be
honest about is that the monarchy is
operating from a position of strength so
Kinsey referred to it wouldn't they look
weak but they have so much that they're
well I think actually establishment they
can afford to give a bit they they are
the ones that can give forward and step
forward with the Olive Branch with
regard to that 25 I always think it's
rather interesting though whenever the
next question is asked and you are right
there is a movement in the Hillary we're
gonna have to wrap it up there
unfortunately we have run out of time uh
sorry to cut you off there because uh we
did want to hear the rest of it but
straight out of time